[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande interview acquérir brief
comprenez je ne peux pas respirer ce
sont les derniers mots de john chevreuil
de mort aux mains d'un policier blanc
lors de son arrestation
floyd est devenu un énième symbole des
violences policières subie par la
communauté noire aux etats unis les
images insoutenables de sa mort ont ému
le monde entier
dès lors les américains ont manifesté
dans tout le pays pour dénoncer ces
bavures policières et le racisme ambiant
malheureusement l'histoire se répète et
le nom de john jowitt s'ajoute à une
longue liste de noirs américains tués
par la police des événements tragiques
qui déclenche un débat sans fin sur le
traitement des minorités par la police
aujourd'hui pour en parler je reçois
ragnar alec journaliste et productrice
de l'émission so box ndao et mafiques
depuis washington dc bonjour à vous
ragnar avec merci d'être avec nous en
direct depuis washington
alors après josh floyd on a cette
impression de déjà vu il y a eu bien
avant bras nati leur frigo et mike brown
affirme mme aubry et plein d'autres
encore pourquoi est-ce que le cas de
georges fed a suscité l'émotion et
pourquoi maintenant à la fing je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs raisons à cela
farage est d'abord si vous regardez les
images ces huit minutes un policier qui
met son genou sur un homme qui suffoque
jusqu'à mourir c'est horrible à regarder
je veux dire il y a plein de vidéos de
violences policières dans ce pays mais
celle là est la pire que je n'ai jamais
vu ensuite je trouve choquant de voir
cet homme se faire torturer jusqu'à la
mort est de constater que des officiers
de police debout à côté ne font rien
dessus de ça nous avons une situation où
économiquement les états unis ne s'en
sortent pas très bien nous avons 40
millions de personnes sans emploi à
cause des mesures du confinement liés
aux coronavirus et peu d'être venant du
gouvernement
donc les gens sont très énervés dans ce
pays est la goutte d'eau a fait déborder
le vase et a rendu les gens en colère de
voir la police sur une vidéo en train de
tuer un homme noir de cette façon en
plus du chaos qui sévit dans le pays
l'équipe fait de nombreux morts plus de
cent mille personnes sont mortes du
coronavirus littéralement parce qu'elles
ne peuvent pas respirer comme les gens
sont en télétravail
ils ont un peu plus de temps pour aller
dans la rue et protester de surcroît
l'anxiété de la pandémie mêlée à la
colère qui monte
après cette vidéo de la police qui tue
ont été des points communs pour lutter
contre le gouvernement il ya aussi la
réponse apportée par la police aux
manifestations de soutien à jean jeu
floyd qui a été extrêmement violente
on l'a vue vidéo après vidéo avec la
police qui utilisaient du gaz au poivre
du gaz lacrymogène frappant des
manifestants sans raison ils étaient
pour la plupart pacifiques
le tout devant les caméras on a même vu
des véhicules de police foncé dans la
foule le tout devant les manifestants
témoins de ces scènes faisant monter
leur niveau de colère et fait descendre
davantage de manifestants dans la rue
mais contrairement à d'autres pays la
ségrégation et des temps très ancrée
dans l'histoire commence le petit que le
pays n'ait pas tourné la page vous devez
comprendre que ce pays s'est construit
sur deux choses
osborne sur l'esclavagé et sur le
génocide des indiens d'amérique
et c'est deux choses en jouer un énorme
rôle dans la naissance de l'économie des
états unis
si ce pays a progressé sur certains
points l'économie elle est restée la
même
elle exploite les plus pauvres et plus
spécifiquement les gens de couleur et
les gens noirs
donc nous avons une histoire
esclavagiste de ségrégation et cela
continue aujourd'hui sous d'autres
manières car cela sert les intérêts des
personnes qui tiennent les rênes de
l'économie américaine
ce rôle économique se trouve aussi dans
le domaine carcéral aux états unis où
nous avons 5 % de la population en
prison ce qui correspond à 25% de la
population carcérale mondiale est parce
qu il y a une grande industrie qui fait
de l'argent en ciblant essentiellement
les communautés pauvres de couleurs vous
savez qu'un homme noir sur trois
connaîtra la prison aux états unis à un
moment de sa vie et il ces choses
existent échanges mais ce système
d'exploitation et de racisme aujourd'hui
prend un nouveau visage avec les
violences policières et les
incarcérations de masse creed beaucoup
de gens noirs pauvres sont dans ce cas
de figure de même qu'il y a dans ce pays
beaucoup de chômage ce qui entraîne la
pauvreté au lieu d' essayer d'arranger
les choses en investissant dans la
communauté noire
on utilise la police puis la prison pour
criminaliser ces personnes et masquer
les problèmes
toutes ces personnes qui sont pauvres et
n'ont pas d'emploi sont stigmatisés et
mis en prison
toutes ces choses joue un rôle dans ce
que nous voyons actuellement avec cette
police qui tue surtout les communautés
pauvres de couleurs rien n'est prise en
compte dans ce pays d'un point de vue
économique au sein des communautés
noires et la police criminalise la
pauvreté justement il ya eu des hommes
politiques des femmes qui on entend un
petit peu profité pour redorer leur
blason il ya eu l est républicain avec
mes romney qui était à une manifestation
où les démocrates mais démocrates avec
même s'il pourra aussi qui a elle aussi
poyer le genou pendant huit minutes vous
en parlait d'ailleurs de manière assez
drôle regarder salut j'essaye de faire
quelque chose pour gagner des points
politiques en exploitant les cultures
noires
j'ai pensé à quelque chose d'africains
un chapeau une écharpe les africains
porte des écharpes
une écharpe kent comment vous appelez ça
intéressant ça ressemble à quoi ça
marcherait si un groupe de politiciens
faussement triste et essayer de sauter
sur un mouvement antiraciste ça
marcherait à excellent j'ai vraiment
besoin de quelque chose comme ça pour
faire en sorte qu'un groupe de blancs
très riche et privilégier fasse semblant
d'être attristé par la situation des
noirs vous savez comme un visage noir
toléré est-ce que les écharpes sont très
colorées elles proviennent du nigeria
elles viennent du ghana si en amérique
du sud
ah d'accord j'étais en train de penser à
la guyane au ketchup
vous auriez 230 écharpe kent en stock
génial je le dis à nancy et quelqu'un
allait récupérer elle sera incroyable
avec on les voit les démocrates à genoux
les policiers l'ont fait aussi certains
crient au scandale estime que cette la
comédie d'autres félicite le geste on
peut se poser une question pourquoi ne
vont-ils pas fait avant il est
intéressant et tout a commencé quand le
joueur de football américain colline cas
pernik a posé un genou à terre au début
d'un match lors de l'hymne américain en
guise de protestation silencieuse à ce
moment là c'est devenu en outrage aux
états unis pour beaucoup de gens et
surtout pour les blancs quand ils ont
commencé à comprendre pourquoi un joueur
de la nfl faisait cela contre les
violences policières
ils étaient en colère qu'on puisse
outragé le pays le drapeau et il se
disait qu'il devait jouer au football et
ne pas se mêler de politique
d'autres joueurs de football ont
commencé par la suite a posé un genou à
terre puisque beaucoup de joueurs sont
noirs et qu'ils ont déjà eu affaire aux
violences policières dans ce pays et
même les démocrates à cette époque
trouver offensant que coline copernic
puisse poser un genou à terre et
maintenant que les violences policières
font les unes des médias de masse
vous avez beaucoup de démocrates et
républicains comme mitt romney que vous
avez mentionné qui tente de sauter sur
l'occasion pour se redorer une image en
n'oubliant pas de tweet et de la clyde
majeur même s'il continue à exploiter la
misère des pauvres travailleurs noirs
sorte qu'honnêtement je trouve cela
insultant
c'est insultant car on a même vu barack
obama condamné l'action de collines
copernic en disant à quel point c'était
offensant de poser un genou à terre et
là on voit les démocrates faire la même
chose devant les caméras pour une
opération de communication afin de
pouvoir utiliser ce mouvement au
bénéfice de la prochaine campagne
électorale
c'est important de se rappeler que les
démocrates comme les républicains sont
coupables de cette injustice ils ont
construit le système le plus raciste
avec désincarcération de masse des
violences policières et le voeu des
budgets en hausse de la police tout ce
dont pourquoi les gens sont en colère
aujourd'hui en fait joe biden le
candidat nominé des démocrates pour la
présidence a joué un rôle significatif
dans les années 90 dans la construction
de ce système qui a incroyablement fait
augmenter le taux d'incarcération des
hommes noirs ils doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités pour ça et au lieu d'
arranger les problèmes que nous avons et
d'engager des réformes
il adopte des gestes contre-productif
comme portée des écharpes africaine qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les afro
américains
c'est une grande plaisanterie justement
en parlant de politique en est il du
président trump les élections à
présidentielle arrive bientôt et ce qu
il s'est tiré une balle dans le pied est
vraiment passé à côté du problème
dans mes souvenirs c'est la première
fois qu'on assiste à des manifestations
de masse où la majorité des américains
sont sympathisants de ces mobilisations
ils savent qu'il ya de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent
vous savez trump fait du bon travail
pour exciter son électorat de base et
les syndicats de police en font partie
cet électorat à une conception assez
autoritaire du système et soutiendra la
police en toutes circonstances mais ce
n'est pas le cas de la majorité du pays
aujourd'hui
trump n'a pas mesuré la situation
notamment envers les pauvres on est très
loin encore de la prochaine élection
présidentielle et la situation actuelle
du pays il ne présage pas ce qui se
passera en novembre comme en 2016 de
plus trump ne sait pas quand ils
dispersent l'ensemble des manifestants
autour de la maison blanche pour une
opération de communication
il communique aujourd'hui sur quelque
chose qui a marché en politique dans le
passé la loi et l'ordre être le
président de la loi et l'ordre contre
ces pseudos manifestants c'est mettre
une étiquette raciale sur ce segment
il n'est pas prouvé en 2020 en amérique
que cette méthode fonctionne et jusqu'à
présent les sondages montrent qu'ils se
trompent pas comment est ce que les
médias mainstream couvre le cas djordje
floyd est ce qu'il y a deux camps celui
du bien ou du mal ou est ce que tous les
médias sont finalement unanimes les
médias américains sont concentrés sur
cette situation comme les partis
politiques
cela dépend du média que vous regardez
si vous regardez foxnews vous verrez
très peu parlé des invités prendre la
cause des policiers et d'autres
cataloguer les manifestants comme des
anti fascistes mais si vous regardez les
médias de masse telles que cnn
ms nbc et que vous lisez le new york
times le washington post
quand ils traitent ces manifestations il
n'hésite pas à dire que cela arrive sous
la présidence de trump et démontre
politiquement que c'est peut-être à
cause de lui aussi sous barack obama il
y avait des manifestations similaires à
ferguson dans le missouri à saint louis
après le meurtre par la police de
michael brown
il ya eu aussi des manifestations
similaires à baltimore après le meurtre
de freddy grrrr
tout cela a eu lieu sous barack obama
car le problème c'est le fait que la
police tue peu importe qui est le
président que ce soit obama outre quand
il y avait des meurtres perpétrés par
des policiers les titres de cnn était
plus sympathique envers la police peu
importe ce que disait la police pour eux
c'était vrai il est affirmé que les
manifestants étaient des pilleurs en
colère et cela a changé sous donald
trump
je ne pense pas que ce soit une mauvaise
chose car cela montre les violences
policières comme nous ne les avons
jamais vu
je pense aussi que la couverture faite
par les médias de masse et les réseaux
sociaux comme twitter et facebook est
complètement différente car on y voit
plus de choses notamment sur les
violences policières que l'on ne voit
pas sur les chaînes de télévision qui
restent davantage du côté des autorités
même si elles ne veulent pas le montrer
on marque une courte pause et en revient
[Musique]
on est retour dans la grande interview
avec ragnar allègue depuis washington
il ya eu plusieurs mouvements engagés
sur les réseaux sociaux comme blake
lively qui existait déjà benoît capt usd
tel est le rôle des réseaux sociaux dans
ce genre d'événement amina le rôle des
réseaux sociaux est très important car
beaucoup de ces histoires ont été virale
avant que les médias mainstream d'en
face les qu il y a eu un cas à new york
celui de elite garner qui a été
étranglée il ya six ans par la police
par une prise d'étranglement illégale et
qui par la suite est décédé cela
n'aurait pas été dans les médias de
masse par exemple s'il n'y avait pas eu
une personne sur le terrain pour filmer
et poster les vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux
quelqu'un est parti en prison à cause de
ce poste les réseaux sociaux sont donc
très importants comme je les
mentionnaient avant si vous comparez les
médias mainstream avec les réseaux
sociaux vous verrez une histoire
différente car les gens prennent des
vidéos sur le terrain et vous montre la
réalité de ce que fait la police
quand ils essayent de manifester quelles
sortes de violence ils subissent sur cnn
ou sur msn dit si vous voyez un
porte-parole de la police fit un autre
donnant leur version des faits est
tentant de nous en convaincre
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de racisme
dans le débat public dans les films les
réseaux sociaux les séries des
documentaires et pourtant les mentalités
semblent figés les inégalités aussi là
que je dirais que les mentalités de msp
personnel ont changé ou change
particulièrement avec les jeunes de même
avec les seniors qui reconnaissent que
nous avons un système rassis et je pense
que c'est important que les gens le
reconnaissent
finci ways le souci c'est que
reconnaître individuellement qu'il y à
du racisme c'est bien mais cela ne
change pas le système
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue ça ne dépend pas de
l'origine ou du sexe ou des intentions
du président qui gouverne de changer les
choses c'est plutôt le système
institutionnel en place qui est raciste
tue qui et contre les gens pauvres et de
couleurs croire c'est ce thème alors oui
je pense que c'est tout le système
économique qu'il faut changer aux états
unis changer notre façon d'investir
il ya un mouvement actuel défendre la
police qui consiste à prendre en compte
la façon de régler les problèmes sociaux
dans la police est débité de
criminaliser et d'incarcérer atout
majeur qui pensent quand les gens
veulent quand ils commettent un crime
c'est souvent le résultat d'une
situation économique
et puis si on investit dans les hlm dans
l'accès aux soins médicaux gratuits
si on prend l'argent du budget de la
police soit plusieurs centaines de
milliards de dollars et que l'on
redirige ses fonds vers des programmes
sociaux cèdera pour réguler un certain
nombre de problèmes que nous avons
d'ordre criminel et d'éviter l'économie
souterraine des gangs et du trafic de
drogue
c'est en changeant le système et en
investissant de l'argent dans le social
que ça changera sinon nous continuerons
à avoir ces problèmes dans une de vos
vidéos vous expliquer qu'il ya des
années en arrière la guerre contre la
drogue aux états unis à criminaliser les
noirs et les amis dans une case
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus vers la fin de la ségrégation
et gentreau il y a eu un nouveau système
raciale qui s'est mis en place notamment
la lutte contre la drogue qui a aussi
coïncidé avec la désindustrialisation
dans beaucoup de villes américaines
laissant des gens sur le carreau et sans
emploi dans les communautés noire et
pauvre en réalité beaucoup n'avaient
plus de travail et nombreux
zinn était délocalisé en conséquence les
bilans massivement investi dans la
police pour criminaliser les gens
pauvres et de couleurs par la lutte
antidrogue beaucoup d'entre eux qui
n'avaient plus rien ont dû passer
légitimement par l'économie souterraine
qui est l'économie de la drogue vendre
de la drogue consommé de la drogue a été
criminalisé à un degré extrême découlant
sur des incarcérations massive et une
explosion du budget de la police en
donnant à celles ci des équipements
militaires et en développant les écuries
je souhaite tout cela en se concentrant
sur les citoyens noirs et pauvres à
travers toute l'amérique
le résultat a été de créer ce système
d'incarcération massive comme je les
mentionnaient avant en ciblant les
pauvres de couleurs car nous avons de
nombreux travailleurs dessous classe
pour lesquels nous n'avons pas de
travail c'est la voie de la pauvreté à
la prison ce système économique va à sa
perte et n'est pas en bonne santé comme
ça l'est dans certains pays européens
donc tous ceux criminalisant les gens
termine en prison et certains quartiers
ont une présence policière massive selon
vous 99% de la police qui est impliqué
dans une fusillade n'est jamais condamné
est ce qu'il ya une impunité assumer
absolument il y a une culture de
l'impunité dans la police américaine
cela va même plus loin dans ceux qui
dirigent les villes les maires les
procureurs sont toujours du côté de la
police
il y a aussi une loi aux états unis qui
nous dit que la police peut tuer
qu'elles peuvent blesser si les
policiers sont une menace ce qui est
très subjectif après son atterrissage
acteurs aliouane tout le monde peut se
sentir menacés donc tout ce qu'a à dire
un policier
c'est qu'il a été menacé par une arme
alors même que la personne était non
armés et les policiers sont rarement
poursuivis et quand ils le sont ils font
souvent face à des jurés blanc qui
décideront de leur sort mais cela
restera car les procureurs ne les
poursuive que très peu cette culture de
l'impunité est l'un des grands sujets
face aux violences policières constante
car on sait qu'ils peuvent passer au
travers il ya une expression qui fait
débat le privilège blanc en france aussi
certains sont pas d'accord et nie
complètement son existence est ce qu aux
etats unis
le wild preuve d'âge est reconnu c'est
une expression très populaire aux états
unis en ce moment la police traite
différemment les blancs et les noirs les
états unis sont vraiment un pays raciste
comme je les dis plutôt c'est important
de reconnaître qu'en tant que blanc vous
pouvez faire des choses que les noirs ne
peuvent pas il faut reconnaître le
caractère institutionnel de cela car
tout le monde peut changer
individuellement mais cela ne fera pas
changer le système à la fin je pense que
beaucoup est encore à faire en se
concentrant sur un changement économique
institutionnel et politique il faudrait
que le vrai changement dont nous avons
besoin deviennent populaires à travers
le monde entier a été ému par la sphère
jean-claude on en a parlé en france dans
le monde entier ont les réactions elles
ont été unanimes
mais quelle est la suite est-ce que
c'est le début de quelque chose
peut-être il y à de nouvelles choses qui
émerge de cette situation aux états unis
comme faire changer la façon de
travailler de la police puis dans un
second temps la manière d'investir vers
des programmes sociaux
c'est déjà arrivé à minneapolis où
georges floyd a été tué
le conseil municipal a voté pour la
dissolution de la police de la ville
pour la reconstruire et mettre plus de
fonds pour des programmes sociaux
cela arrive dans d'autres villes à
travers le pays
je n'ai jamais vu autant de majorité
d'américains soutenir de telles réformes
donc je pense qu'il ya une grande
opportunité de changer et d'aller plus
loin que la simple réduction de budget
alloué à la police lundi chris sparling
pour dit on pourrait réduire le budget
du pentagone qui s'est efforcé à
militariser la police et d'autres police
à l'étranger avec un budget de près de
800 milliards à l'année ça fait beaucoup
les gens commencent à voir ce genre de
détails ou énormément d'argent est
dépensé de la sorte pour la police alors
que beaucoup de monde a faim personnes
emploi et ne peut payer son loyer
donc ce mouvement s'il continue aidera à
y voir plus clair d'un point de vue
économique
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce que selon
vous les questions d'identité sont dans
le débat public sont plus importantes
qu'il y a quelques années pourquoi ce
besoin de se revendiquer hamilton qui
porte je pense que les gens se sentent
plus forts
vous savez les états unis est un pays
d'immigrés qu'on parle de deuxième voire
troisième génération d'immigrés mais
ceux qui sont arrivés en premier les
arrière grands parents sont beaucoup
plus silencieux
ils ne veulent pas être politiquement
impliqué alors que leurs enfants qui ont
grandi élevé aux états unis et qui sont
allés à l'école ici réalistes que leurs
origines sont absentes des livres
d'histoire réalistes qu'ils ont été
traités d'une façon différente que les
blancs qui n'ont pas eu les mêmes
opportunités que les blancs alors que le
pays se proclame la terre de la liberté
de l'égalité et norbert
donc nous avons une jeune génération
plus audible et visible qui détient le
pouvoir d'être debout pour ses droits en
corrélation avec les autres minorités
aux états unis nous avons eu la lutte
pour les droits civiques mais aussi la
lutte contre les violences policières
dans les années 90 et vous voyez que
cela arrive encore aujourd'hui les noirs
réalise qu'il faut toujours se battre
pour la justice encore et encore
mais quand toutes ces minorités
s'unissent pour combattre ces
discriminations et donc se sentent plus
forte mais aussi les jeunes gens
prennent conscience et participe au
désir d'avoir un pays qui reflète ses
valeurs d'unité
là c'est une question un peu plus
personnelle rania khaleq 7 toutes ces
expériences qu'est ce qu'elles vont vous
qu'est ce qu'elle vous ont appris qu est
ce que vous avez ressenti ces derniers
années dans tous ces débats enquêtes en
termes d'identité
en tant que journaliste américaine ayant
des parents qui ont immigré aux états
unis du liban à enzo j'ai grandi entre
deux cultures et c'est très inspirant de
voir les minorités mais aussi des jeunes
blancs s'unir ensemble afin de réclamer
une justice sociale
elle retrouve à cannes tout comme une
justice économique je suis aussi une
grande fervente de la lutte pour cette
identité et donc je suis heureuse de
voir que cela arrive actuellement la
lutte pour le droit des minorités
coïncide avec la volonté de régler les
problèmes économiques par exemple la
gratuité des soins médicaux que nous
n'avons pas aux états unis mais
également le salaire minimum
il y à un mouvement pour l'augmenter
donc en tant que journaliste voir tout
cela se passait est assez captivant
surtout que cela arrive dans mon propre
pays
finalement les gens demandent une
justice sociale autant qu'une justice
raciale mais également économique
merci rana callac d'avoir été
avec nous depuis washington je rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste et productrice
pour l'émission so box ndao et ma fic
merci de votre fidélité vous pouvez
revoir cette grande interview sur rtl
france ptv
[Musique]